[Music]
how did you become interested in the
philosophy of maths I became interested
in the philosophy of maths for a number
of reasons I think numbers or
mathematical objects in general are very
very interesting objects of study but
one thing I noticed was that
philosophical questions that are being
asked in different areas of philosophy
are very very similar but philosophers
working in these different fields tend
to not really talk to each other very
much
and in particular philosophy of
mathematics works in a relatively
isolated way and so only only recently
Philosopher's have started picking up on
parallels between philosophy of maths on
the one hand and ethics for example or
meta ethics on the other hand and
they've started drawing very interesting
analogies between these two different
domains and so that's what I'm I'm
researching and researching the
evidential force of using mathematics as
a conceptual model okay that sounds like
very far removed from you know the daily
kind of experience how did he you know
what I don't even know where like you
start with something like that um are
you analyzing than mathematics and the
structures a matter of mathematics in
the abstract or the way that applies to
the way we perceive reality so I think
it might be helpful to think about it in
to to illustrate what I'm talking about
to consider how the relationship between
mathematics on the one hand and the
empirical sciences on the other hand has
developed so in ancient Greece
mathematics was considered the highest
form of knowledge knowledge about
eternal forms and so it was as it were
eternal truths that mathematics embodies
whereas the empirical world was a world
of mere opinion weak
only form beliefs about the empirical
world but we could never have actual
knowledge about the empirical world so
mathematics and the empirical world were
very very far removed from one another
and that changed during the times of the
Scientific Revolution when Galileo
coined the term of mathematics being the
language of the book of nature so all of
a sudden Science and Mathematics Petite
became two sides of the same project as
it were and then later on again the for
sort of the fortunes of mathematics got
a lot worse so during empiricist times
in the nineteenth century mathematics
was only considered a tool for the
empirical sciences and only empirical
knowledge was considered well grounded
knowledge and today we're at a point
where mathematical reality sort of
exists independently of our empirical
reality and there are intersections in
the area of applied mathematics but
there is also a large part of
mathematics that is completely
independent from the empirical world and
we use that part of mathematics we use
this idea of mathematics as this unified
whole where all truths are fully
determinate we use that as a model when
we think about other things in our lives
for example when we think about ethics
or metaphysics and philosophy or even
religion we want all these domains to
look as much as possible like
mathematics fully determinate one answer
to every open question etc etc and so
yeah I'm interested in the extent to
which mathematics has influenced our
conceptualization of these different
areas is it problematic that we want
ethics to function like math it is it is
problematic in some sense and it might
actually not be the correct picture of
mathematics anymore so that's that's
also what triggered my interest in this
project that it looks like mathematics
is moving towards a very robustly
pluralistic picture of the mathematical
realm so it turns out that in some in
some area of mathematics notably in set
theory some mathematicians have
suggested that we should give up the
hunt for the the one unique correct
answer to open mathematical questions
and just accept that there are different
mathematical universes in each one in
each one of which the same mathematical
statement can be sometimes true and
sometimes false and this is an approach
in mathematics that is taken very very
seriously
and I'm wondering what that might mean
for other areas of our lives where we're
we're still thinking in terms of one
unified whole
and given that mathematics has always
influenced the way we thought about
other aspects of reality I think also
the pluralistic move in mathematics will
have a long-term effect so in terms of
ethics does that there's a more
pluralist approach to math also
encourage a more pluralist approach to
ethics or a more relativist one
relativistic one so that's what I'm
thinking about at the moment and I'm my
guess is that yes there might be
connections
I think certainly it might turn out that
we don't need definite answers to all
the questions we're asking it might be
that in order to get along in sort of in
our life together with other human
beings we do need to decide on certain
very fundamental questions but it might
be the case that sort of higher-order
questions we don't need to answer in a
definite way and I think that would
already be a pretty revolutionary result
with that if that's what happened
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you